[Music]
everyone this is kevin from the chess
website calm today we're gonna be
looking at a pretty cool defense one
that I actually really enjoyed playing
with and it's the French defense and the
French defense is a defense against
White's opening move of efore if you
played chess for any matte time you know
that white likes to start out with efore
very frequently so to have multiple
defenses that you can use against this
is always recommended in a chess game a
lot of people you see obviously like to
play the Sicilian the c5 a lot of people
just mare and play e5 but today we're
gonna go over the French defense and
it's actually my favorite defense
against whites play of the e4 square it
definitely has its pros and cons we're
gonna go over those today and I'm gonna
kind of go over some of the key concepts
that you want to look for when you play
the French defense but I feel like it
gives you a very good opportunity to
counter-attack especially on the Queen
side a lot of times you'll see in the
French defense that the white attack is
going to be aimed at the Kings side
while black is trying to counter on the
Queen side but I feel
Phil you have a lot of good options and
we're gonna kind of go over those so it
starts out for those aren't who aren't
too familiar with it pawn to e4 White's
first move and black responds pawn to e6
now this does a couple things and I'm
gonna go and take a look at this
position this right here is the French
defense starting position but as you can
imagine we are trying to gain Center
control but not with our very first move
so our second move is we eventually want
d5 and that's for the most part across
the board going to be our second move
but keep in mind a couple things right
off the bat that we can look at our
ecigs
moved as a couple things and once we
move our pawn to d5 we have started a
blockade along this a2 all the way to G
a diagonal and that's a very key
diagonal for white as our f7 Square for
black is a very key weakness for us and
so we are going to start in a defense
along this diagonal white usually tends
to prefer his LightSquared bishop so he
can reign down an attack on the sevens
f7 square but the French defense does a
really good job of muting that attack
right off the beginning we're gonna go
ahead and start a defense along this
diagonal and white it's not gonna be
able to do much as far as attacking our
f7 square early on another thing that
you want to keep in mind and this is
actually a very common theme and the
French defense is we have blocked our
Bishop our Queen Bishop on the CA
squared in
even after we move our pawn to d5 and
develop our LightSquared Bishop is going
to be trapped in here obviously you
don't want to trap your pieces and
that's not a good thing so eventually we
will want to free that piece up white
should if they've played against the
French defense they should hone down on
our weakness any time you're playing
someone you always want to look for
their weakness what they have and attack
that but keep in mind this is going to
be our weakness our our Queen Bishop
square so more than likely we're going
to develop it along the B or a6 and use
it in this attack because again as we
said it's kind of blocked off here
because of our East six work but that is
not as important our King Bishop is
actually the most important as it is in
most any game and so we're gonna use
that to our to our full advantage here
and kind of go over some of the some of
the common things but those are just a
couple things you want to you want to
keep in mind if you are having problems
defending your f7 square this may be a
very good defense for you just because
right off the bat you're basically
telling white hey you know I'm not gonna
let you attack my my weakness here so
you're gonna have to try to exploit a
Queen Bishop weakness which is a little
harder for white to exploit if he's not
a very good chess player so many times
there's two main lines that we're gonna
go over today of the that white can
white can employ here a lot of times
you'll see d4 obviously White's trying
to gain sooner control is with any
opening and right now there's no defense
against that so he's gonna go ahead and
take the center another one you'll see
is simply just c3 and those can be in
different orders but we're going to go
ahead and go over those we're not
actually too worried about f3 to be
honest with you
he's attacking the e5 square which we
don't have a piece there and he's
attacking the d4 square which we're not
gonna have a piece there so if he moves
g3 that that's completely fun a lot of
people don't know how to play against
the French defense and so they'll go
ahead and develop to the f3 square but
you know I don't really like that
because I feel like they just don't know
what they're doing so they just continue
their development as they normally would
efore and then Knight to f3 but we're
not gonna go over that because I don't
really think that's the best move for
white so we're gonna go ahead and go
over the main lines that you'll see
often and kind of what you should look
at first most common thing you'll see is
just d4 pawn to d4 trying to control the
center for white and here the obvious
move for black is to bring his pawn to
d5 basically attacking white Center
control here and keep in mind the theme
that we have here is black is trying to
control the light squares light squares
you know it doesn't matter if you
control the light are the dark squares
but you you know early on you should
have a theme in what you want to do is
kind of work around that theme and
adjust what your opponent's doing and
the French defense we're gonna be honing
down on the light squares another very
key square that you want to look at is
the c5 square and pretty much all the
games I play the c5 square is a vital
vital piece square that you want to to
look at eventually we want to bring our
pawn to c5 and as you can tell we have
our bishop on f8 attacking that and we
don't even mind if white takes that
because we can develop with tempo here
and take a piece and develop our Bishop
with great center control so that's
obviously obviously and we're also
attacking the center as well so
eventually we want to play this
because we have a great defense so why
it's gonna have to figure out how he
wants to hold on to this d4 square
because they obviously any time we can
just if he doesn't attack us we can take
this piece on on d4 and kind of
undermine his center control so two
moves you'll see here and we'll kind of
go over both of them the first move
you'll see is just pawn to e5 a lot of
times white doesn't like to give up
their sin of control and so they'll just
move forward one piece one space here
and I actually really like playing this
as black just because I feel like
White's kind of moved two pawns and
blacks kind of moved two pawns I don't
feel like either has a better position
than the other and now I feel like it's
blacks turn so I almost feel like we
have the initiative even though we've
gone we play second in the match here so
from here I like to go ahead and just
place five it adds constant pressure on
this d5 square and white is going to
have to try to figure out how they want
to defend that you may see this by g3
you may see it by c3 it doesn't really
matter a lot of times white just wants
to try to defend it again defend against
this so we'll go ahead and look at a
common one that I see personally I would
like to see you know c3 just because it
blocks the development of the b3 square
and if you see these sort of mistakes
from your opponent you should definitely
hone in on them but a lot of times
you'll just see white develop his knight
here to f3
defending his pawn if white decides to
capture then again as we talked about
black can come in and recapture with his
bishop and we have great Center control
we'll go ahead and and look what that
would look like
if white captured and then black
recaptured you can already see we have
great Center control here with a
developed Bishop raining down on White's
weakness at the F 2 square and White has
one pawn on the e5 score that's not
doing too much so if they do decide to
capture you know all the all the power
to them I just don't think that's a very
good move but after Knight to f3 we're
gonna add more pressure to this square
right here and we're gonna just bring
our Knight to c6 and then white can
continue to figure out what they want to
do as far as defending this this key
square here the the d4